[Music]
I'm the one
okay so Adam first of all you're
supposed to apparently you're not
supposed to be here yeah because people
thought that was your last week last
week uh people have been you know
rooting for my dad dude three years
I got of people going two-sided hell
yeah Pat got rid of them and then other
people going you're stupid and loud and
I was like good good anyways we're uh
live supposed to be birthday dry out
week yes Adam is back from uh you were
aware you were Jackson Hole Wyoming go
check it out if you uh want to have an
alternative to Aspen or Veil it's one of
the rich people hang out
that's kind of a cool chill Place yeah
that's actually where Vinnie would pinch
Bears yeah because
this is an inside joke if anyone was
pinching Bears this morning because
anyways but by the way so I was gone for
uh I missed I think two part did I miss
anything nothing crazy
[Music]
straight up I want us to kind of uh if
any of the stories scare you tell me I
won't bring it up to you if you're not
comfortable with it okay so let's get
into it these are some of the stories
that we plan on talking about today
number one that's not Ron is it
ex-president Donald Trump post a photo
of Florida Governor Rhonda since is
allegedly drinking and partying with
high school girls okay here we go
Governor voters uh GOP voters are
picking DeSantis over Trump in a
hypothetical head-to-head matchup this
is CNBC uh Cuomo blast biting over
migrant crisis the southern uh states
were right Cuomo's going after Brighton
what does that mean we have no clue
we'll talk about it fed official on uh
officials on board with more modest pace
of interest rate hikes Jamie dimon warns
it's too early to declare Victory
against inflation Google to beef up
search on AI Tom's got a lot of thoughts
on that with alphabet it's interesting
what's going on they're the layoffs
whether it's Disney 7000 whether it's R
Kathy Wood
talking about the reasoning behind the
layoffs or Yahoo announcing that 20 uh
of the folks are going to be laid off at
Yahoo Wozniak goes after Elon Musk okay
musk fires a top Twitter engineer people
are curious on why that is taking place
uh this guy named LeBron James became
the all-time scorer but we're not going
to cover that we just recognize it's a
big deal congratulations to the guy high
school students suspended and arrested
for saying there's only two genders
Toronto's son catastrophic gay couple
charged with raping Sons pimp them out
to pet is that the story you pimped them
out recorded it and then made porn and
then yeah is this the they're going they
got nine nine countries but I haven't I
have an opinion on what should really
happenings are pouring into Nevada and
people in Nevada are not happy about it
and then at the end maybe we'll make
some uh both predictions does Nevada
have state income tax
maybe there's a benefit about it so
anyways by the way something happened
with O'Keefe I know you're looking into
the story we'll talk about O'Keefe as
well on what happened but why don't we
go right into the economy uh page five
uh uh if you want to go into page five
first story is going to be a I believe
it's a Reuters story let me see if I can
find that official story yeah let me get
to it okay here we go fed officials on
board with more modest raid hikes this
is a reuter story according to Fed
officials more interest interest rate
hikes are expected as a central bank
aims to cool inflation New York fed
President John Williams stated that
moving a federal funds rate of between a
half a point I'm sorry five points to
five and a quarter seems a very
reasonable view of what we'll need to do
this year however he also noted that the
FED would probably be able to make us
take smaller steps relative to the pace
of past tightening campaigns Jerome
Powell added that if we continue to get
for example strong labor market reports
or higher higher inflation reports it
may well be the case we have to do more
okay
Williams also emphasized importance of
monetary policy to get into State levels
will strain okay anyways
um Tom what are your thoughts when hear
a story like this based on what Powell
is saying and last month 517 000 job
report new jobs which is a good number
and then we're going to talk about the
layoffs here in a minute what do you
think is going to be happening with
rates here wow there's a whole bunch of
things to unpack here first of all we
can talk about the jobs really really
fast and about how some of these jobs
are people getting back to work after
coved and it's a lot of hospitality jobs
that are in there but when you get that
report that the White House does a
Victory lap on down the street Powell
sees that and goes I got to keep raising
raids this this economy is too hot so
it's it's uh does the White House really
want Powell to be reacting like that and
it's important what you just said it's
important what you just said so the more
the numbers look better the more he will
increase rates because remember what's
pal looking for two percent inflation
he's looking for two percent until he
can see two percent he's staying up in
the bedroom with the cheerleader so we
that's right you know we can't forget
the church
pounding the poor economy but um
so that's part one part two part two of
this is what Powell is saying is okay
I'm only gonna go to quarter points and
I'm going to stretch them out a little
bit but he's still raising rates he's
still raising so what he's saying is
yeah the economy now has a great point
is now got uh about 50 percent heading
towards 60 so it's still an F heading
toward a d but it's getting better
that's all Powell is saying is I'm going
to stretch it out but I'm still raising
rates so rates are still going to be
going up mortgages aren't going to be
going down and what was very interesting
and I flipped you a text on this uh
yesterday is but Jamie dimon is saying
hey we're not out of the woods yet and
down the street at B of A because you
know Jamie's uh JP Morgan Chase down the
street at BNA their research yesterday
was talking about the same charts that
we talked about on the podcast almost a
month ago about savings and credit card
debt and they're saying it's not going
to take much unemployment for this to be
a very hard Landing so we're not out of
the woods yet and I think that's what
all of this is pointing to here's what's
crazy do you know when is the last time
do you know how many time we increased
the rates last year 2022 not including
one we did this year how many times we
increased rates last year six times
seven times last year was seven times do
you know when was the last time we
increased the rate seven times in one
year do you know what's the last time we
did that
19506 2005 is the last increase of seven
times okay we did eight times uh one
time which we increased it eight times
in a year but so anytime the rates go
the way they're going what follows is
unemployment that's the Phillips curve
the Phillips curve says interest rates
inflation high unemployment low you flip
it inflation unemployment High inflation
interest rates are low so those things
go against each other right so the way
it's looking right now if they keep
pushing I know if any this is something
you study very closely if they keep
pushing this unemployment is going to
crash tremendously by the way fun fact
fun fact you ready for this yes sir how
many times you think we lowered interest
rates the most in a single year what is
the record of the most times we ever
lowered interest at what was the year
and how many times was it I'd be so
curious enough you know you're probably
not going to get it right so don't go to
the year you're thinking you're going to
go because it's economic expansion it's
a different year what is
the most times we lowered interest rates
in a year I just want you to know before
as you guys think I just went from
Fearless to fearful like right now it
just happened I'm first of all what do
you think
was it 2008 When we dropped everything
to a half a point and we dropped like
five times now what is the most times we
lose most interest rates in a year
once I'm I'm guessing this pure
speculation was under Ronald Reagan okay
so it was 2001. okay but then here's the
question how many times did we lower it
how many times have we lower it in one
year in one year it's a crazy number
like I had to keep reading this article
over and over and over because I
couldn't believe it
is it eight nine times so is that the is
that the nine time drop it was in 2001
and and people are commenting right now
because they Googled it 11 times
that was a nuclear winner that was a
tough question lower and lower and lower
and back to back to back to back so look
you know the the feds controlled what
happens to the economy okay when you
hear the Saint Jerome Powell's the most
powerful it's not because he you know
it's just the state he really is but
right now everybody is trying to kind of
get Powell to play along and Powell the
good thing about pow which is kind of
weird he's the the guy that's the Fed
chair who was put in there by a guy
named Donald and he's still there by a
guy named Joe okay which means he
doesn't he's not he doesn't favor the
right he doesn't favor the left he used
to work for Carlisle group with
Rubenstein so to him he's just saying
guys I have he's one dimensional two
percent to get there he's going to keep
increasing interest rates which is going
to be very weird on how bad not
everybody now is saying well it's going
to be a soft Landing it's going to be
soft Landing it's going to be soft
Landing you know what's a great thing
when people say things like that
paranoia disappears you know what what
happens when paranoia disappears
the bit the best opportunities come
right after paranoia disappears the best
opportunities to things to buy is when
people get cocky people are starting to
get a little bit cocky again about the
fact that this inflation thing this
recession thing is going to come by Adam
what are you thinking by the way I'd
just like to get a running tab this is
something we should consistently do Rob
would you pull up the fear greed index
with CNN what they typically oh the
monitor where the markets are right now
that'd just be good to kind of
monitorial what do you think we were we
went from full-on fearful 30 days ago I
think it's green it's a little bit
greedy right I think we are I would say
we're I'd say we're in the green index
I'd say we're in the green oh look at
that look at it now a little greedy
we're getting greedier I think it was at
60 something percent a week ago so I
don't know we're we're we've moved out
of the the fearful state of the economy
into and by the way look look at what
you're saying right there this is very
important what Adam is saying zoom in a
little bit zoom in look at one year ago
what was the score everybody was scared
33 a year ago about a month ago we were
51 yeah so from 51 we've gone to 72 and
a week ago was 76 which is extremely
greedy I don't know interestingly yeah
how how I know it is significantly so is
this greedy for me meaning like people
like you know the their their cause so
their houses are going down and people
are buying or buying more you know
you're no longer like staying tight 99
store you're not going there anymore oh
wow it's the opposite of fear he's like
all right let me get out there and
explore a little bit fearful Fearless
like people are fearless today today's
Fearless yeah well I think since you're
you're kind of giving us a history
lesson on uh the amount of uh race uh
interest rate hikes and and lowering it
I think it's important to to note it's
currently at 4.5 we're talking about the
FED fund rate right and that's the the
rate at which what commercial Banks loan
each other overnight money to match
reserves is that that that's essentially
within his right Tom uh and then it's
obviously the FED uses interest rates
and rate hikes to cut kind of cool
inflation
uh stat for you
um we talk about what mortgage rates
were in the like the this for sale or no
and we should put it on no I'm asking
you serious questions I was just looking
at it looks like everybody's saying you
look like Maverick you look sick on
camera but it's not for sale no it is
for sale you could buy it off my back
right now
[Laughter]
for three thousand dollars my shoes are
for
CES history lesson we talked about how
in the 80s uh interest rates mortgages
were double digits do you know what the
FED fund rate was in 1980 when Ronald
Reagan took over presidency 20 that's
what banks charged each other oh wow to
borrow money 20 are you kidding me it's
at four point five percent by the way it
went down to zero percent in 2008 and
then during covid so these dramatic rate
hikes and and lowering the rates this is
essentially this is what makes America
tick right we get so caught up in
politics and [__] Joe Biden and [__]
Trump and this but this is the the we
talk about Jerome power being the most
powerful man in America these rates are
wildly different and how does this
affect you this affects you with your
mortgage with your loans with your car
loans what about your paid in student
loans whether it cost to borrow money
small business loans these are the
numbers you got to kind of pay attention
credit cards for sure it goes right next
to the store here to transition after
perfect timing for this Jamie Diamond
warns it's too early to declare Victory
against inflation JP Morgan Chase Jamie
Diamond suggests that the Federal
Reserve could raise interest rates
higher than expected if price pressure
persists his comments come amid growing
signs of inflation in the U.S economy
including the strong January jobs report
Diamond says people should take a deep
breath on this one before they declare
Victory because a month numbers looked
good the hiring surgeon January has
complicated the fed's fight to lower
prices and tame inflation some of the
which uh stems from the imbalanced labor
market employers added a whopping 517
000 jobs that's what I talked about
earlier nearly triple what Wall Street
expected by the way that is insane once
again like to talk about the timing was
perfect right before uh State of the
Union speech for President Biden 517
000 jobs they were expecting a third of
that okay while the unemployment rate
has dropped to 3.4 percent first time
since May of
1969. okay may of 1969 the Fed last week
voted to raise its Benchmark interest
rates to four and a half to 4.75 and
signaled that more increases could come
this year so these are going together
Jamie's saying relax pump the brakes
don't celebrate too early but then
layoffs let's talk about the layoff
stories okay so layoff stories then you
hear if you can bring up the Disney
so Disney comes out and says we're
cutting 7 000 jobs and slashing five and
a half billion dollars in cost as it
unveils vast restructuring this is a
CNBC story
dizzy said Wednesday's planning on
planning to reorganize into three
segments while also cutting thousands of
jobs and slashing custom media and
entertainment giant set it would now be
made up of three divisions Disney
entertainment which includes most of its
streaming and media operations ESPN
division that includes a TV network and
ESPN streaming services a Parks
experiences and product units the only
reason a person like Bob Iger would do
that is because maybe he's planning on
selling one of the three who knows
that's the way you break it apart
because to say well we're now three
different so hey if you want to buy one
of them well we're kind of for sale
again I'm not saying anything I'm just
speculating on Wednesday during its
quarterly earnings call with investors
Disney also announced it would be
cutting five and a half billion dollars
in costs which will be made up three
billion dollars from content including
Sports and remaining two and a half
billion dollars from non-content Cuts
Disney also said it would be eliminating
7 000 jobs from its Workforce that would
be about 3 percent of roughly two
hundred and twenty thousand people it
employs that's a lot of people Tom what
are your thoughts on this well there's a
couple things going on here first of all
if any of you out there has got some
walking around money you got a couple
billion dollars and you ever wanted to
own ESPN that thing is for sale it's
been bleeding subscribers for literally
a decade and it's not getting any better
you've seen big money
um celebrity commentators have been not
renewed they've trimmed they've called
The Herd as they say and then on the
other side of it I I dove into this it
turns out Hulu's doing okay so Hulu is
doing okay they had some national
markets on streaming not doing so well
but this is basically Iger coming back
to turn this into a business and they
really over hired in a lot of areas they
had a lot of international things and
then he's looking at this ESPN thing
saying what do I do with this because
right now Hulu and Disney plus are
really covering for ESPN on the
streaming side because this he's got a
great portfolio a great offering and the
problem is ESPN is dragging it and then
parks are trying to make a comeback and
they've had all the controversy where
we've heard about oh we're going to
raise the price in Parks so that way
there'll be less people in line for
everybody that finally goes to the parks
remember that they were doing that
around December hey any holiday
travelers to go and then they've also
got a You Know believe it or not it's
very real what's going on in Florida
with the tax change that's real when
companies go you'll read about companies
opening factories and places and they
get a tax break from the from the state
where they build the factory or
something automakers have made a ton of
money Alabama gave money to uh Mercedes
and Tennessee gave money to Toyota
please open your factories here employ
some workers help our local economy and
ESPN has kind of poke the Bear in
Florida so you're seeing Bob Iger do
what the CEO of Disney needed to do but
he has the permission to do it because
he's coming back with an expectation for
change this has been much more difficult
with an entrenched CEO suddenly saying
I'm going to do all this stuff so so
they buy what companies Bob iger's known
he was with ABC Disney for 38 40 years
whatever the time it's a great book if
you've never read the right of a
lifetime sick book we had all employers
leader it's a phenomenal book to read
the guy's a beast like Bob Iger is a
beast okay he's the type of guy that
could have ran for president he may one
day do it he's that capable
he's a heavyweight so he bought Pixar
Marvel Star Wars what else did they buy
ESPN a big box Library box he owns com
codes 24 billion dollars for the other
part of so so do you think do you think
the buying spree was a little too
aggressive when money was cheap or do
you think it was the right move to go
doing what they did what years were that
they're not in the same time the
timeline of when he bought all the
different companies was is a I mean it
took him years to buy Steve Jobs come it
took him years to go through you know so
it was a lot of relationship with him
and Steve Jobs very interesting it's a
good relationship yeah because because
originally jobs was hated Disney and
then he was very upset at the way Disney
treated him the guy that was before uh
uh Bob Iger and he says I just didn't
like the way he was treated then Bob
came in and says would you mind having a
meeting no and then finally it was open
to the idea then they had the
conversation and eventually when he sat
there negotiating with jobs he kind of
got the feel that he was ready and then
jobs called him back and then boom a
deal was struck and by the way when jobs
passed away a lot of people thought his
money was made from Apple yeah he was
the biggest shareholder of Disney oh not
apple he was the biggest single biggest
shareholder in Disney uh not Apple so
for him it was a lot of his net worth
was increasing because of
Disney but here's a question for you you
said something subtly Tom you said
Florida taxes Florida taxes right the
scientists vows to have Disney paid's
fair share of taxes there's a new
sheriff in town this is a fox Tampa Bay
story right yes there's a new sheriff in
town declare Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis during a press conference in
Ocala that's just the way it's going to
be the Santa's proposal bill that would
keep a special taxing district in place
but given a new name and create
five-person board appointed by the
governor he insisted that this would
allow for closer monitoring of the
district without requiring taxpayer to
take on Disney's Financial Obligations
they're not going to have their own
government here wow what a thing for
Disney to say Disney is going to pay its
fair share of taxes and Disney is going
to honor the debt however Florida
Democrats argue that the bill is a
political maneuver by the census and
does not address Disney's special perks
or closer corporate tax loopholes of
census also argues that closer oversight
will give the State a more accurate
picture of Disney's land value and
service efficiency so there's a question
for you for you Tom and I'll open it up
you guys can banter
what is the likelihood what's the
likelihood that Bob Iker and DeSantis
have had a private meeting already oh
very likely 100 Yeah a hundred percent
okay and who's making the request who's
making the demands there's a big
difference between requests and demands
who's making requests who's making
demands
I think iger's making requests that
DeSantis is making demands I agree
Sanders is saying you got to pay your
property taxes and I demand you do it
Iger is saying hey look this goes way
back to Disney building all these jobs
and bringing all this tourism every time
you you pay a little tax on a hotel room
in Florida because you went to Disney
theme park Disney doesn't get that
Florida gets that tax so I guess like
look at this economy that we've made you
know for you in Florida giving you all
this tax people buying food and coming
to visit Disney we get the ticket the
theme park you get the tax on food
lodging car rental all the things that
they do come on dude please so he's
making the request and the Santa sand
listen I don't want this woke stuff I'm
going to tear this thing up and you're
going to pay your taxes who wins
I think in the end
if you put this to the voters Disney if
you put it only to the Florida voters I
don't think this is a winning argument
for Disney well but here's my question
him saying something like you know less
less of the woke stuff do you think Ron
and Florida is so big and powerful for
that like especially the tax thing that
this is going to change their entire
walk agenda to try to you know I mean
get into Florida because I just saw a a
cartoon that they put on Disney uh plus
I don't know if you guys saw that it was
it was like it was a really really
racial type of like do you think they're
gonna there you think that they'll
change because of something like that
this isn't about woke anymore this is by
the way Biden is arguing and and helping
DeSantis every time he goes out attacks
the billionaires make them pay their
fair share those kind of voices come in
from Washington actually helped the
Santa's because the average voter in
Florida says hey you're right maybe a
long time ago Disney got a tax break but
why aren't they paying their fair share
of property taxes and things today I'll
kind of allow you to really elaborate
attack stuff here's where I want to go
with this though you know A wise man
once told me choose your enemies wisely
okay it's a great title for a book so be
careful look out for that coming soon
and I think Ron is pretty calculated and
again I'm not getting into the tech
stuff I'm talking more culture wars and
choosing your enemy wisely and Ron when
he won re-election gave an entire speech
and like the the mic drop moment was he
says Florida is where woke goes to die
and essentially he knows exactly what
he's doing he's sort of using Disney as
the poster boy or The Whipping Boy for
the woke agenda especially in Florida
and Ron said okay how can I pinpoint
business Florida woke agenda what
company should I pinpoint this is pre
Bob Iger Bob iger's been CEO again now
what three months six months Max and he
said this is where I want to pinpoint my
agenda this is exactly the type of
company exactly the type of woke agenda
that I'm gonna go after and it's working
for him him I just don't know if it at
some point this is going to backfire I
don't know but for right now it's
definitely working for you yeah so the
Santa said back in November 30th when
him and Mike Bob Iger had a Feud He said
we didn't drag them in they went in on
their own and not only opposed the bill
threatened to get it repealed they
brought this on themselves I don't care
what a Burbank California based company
says about our laws yeah here's the
thing go ahead no I was just going to
say I vividly remember this is probably
two years ago you did an entire how-to
on the difference between Florida Disney
versus California Disney and everything
that was happening in Florida and Free
State of Florida DeSantis and versus
what was going on in California lockdown
Gavin Newsom there were some Stark
differences but but I'm gonna tell you
this here's what I'm gonna tell you
obviously we all know who DeSantis is
you know from from the perspective of
he's tough he's strong he's a leader
he's not going to compromise you know he
come across as an extremely valued base
guy all of this stuff he's the type of
guy that if you're in war he would be
the guy that would be calling shots
leading you visualize him as that leader
doesn't fear he'll stand up against
anybody right
but but here's Bob Iger from my POV of
what Bob iger's point of view I see Bob
Iger being the Kissinger personality
that's willing to sit with anybody and
negotiate talking to enemies and getting
the enemy to be calm to speak with them
in a reasonable manner without offending
them that's what I see Bob Iger which
means to me I I think this would be
pay-per-view type of conversations if it
was public talk that you can see the
scientists and Iger have an hour two
hour meeting I think it's uh you know
great for television you know be great
television uh to see those to go at it
because it's two different style of
getting things done and they're both
very very effective the scientists set
with heavyweights but Bob iger's also
said with some real real heavy weights
over the years so one is free business
and political exactly you got the free
market heavyweights you got the other
set which is political heavyweight so
yeah anyways we're gonna see what's
gonna happen here but that's Disneyland
there's more to it layoffs you got Yahoo
announcing the fact that they're laying
off 20 of their staff by the end of the
year beginning this week this is also
CNBC story
Yahoo will lay off more than 20 of its
work Workforce by the end of 2023
eliminating a thousand positions alone
one this week alone private Equity Firm
Apollo Global Management acquired 90 of
Yahoo from Verizon in September 2020
when the company had about 10 000
employees at the time axios reported
that more than 1600 workers will lose
their jobs in the latest Cuts suggesting
the company's current head count is
closer to 8 000 employees the layoffs
are part of broader effort by the
company to streamline operations in
Yahoo's advertising unit to Yahoo for
business segment strategy has struggled
to live up to the high standards across
the entire stack according to Yahoo
spokesman given the new focus of the
Yahoo Yahoo advertising company we will
reduce the workforce of the former Yahoo
for business division by nearly 50 by
the end of 2023. so here's the thing how
much of this Tom okay with Yahoo and
with Disney and with Microsoft not
Microsoft with apple and with Amazon and
with you know everybody how much of it
is layoffs because of interest rates
inflation economy and how much of it is
because Disney royally screwed up
because Yahoo is on its way down it's
been going down for a while whether it's
a good economy or a bad economy Yahoo
had a shot 15 years ago to dominate The
Marketplace they missed their Mark Yahoo
could have bought Twitter for six
billion dollars Yahoo has made so many
bad decisions over the last few years
they're a perfect book for a case study
any regular Professor from any business
school can do a case study on Yahoo of
55 things not to do they're a picture
perfect story for that company but how
much of this is bad mistakes how much of
it is it's a bad economy people are
tightening up uh I think this is 80
economy and then 20 we're getting a
window into what's happened at companies
remember when the economy goes down and
the layoffs start happening
for those of you listening and you you
sit there I see layoffs all the time
have you ever had a situation where you
were cleaning out your closet you're
going to give a few things maybe to
Goodwill Salvation Army and all of a
sudden you clean a bunch more stuff out
of your closet you really organize it
and you drop some things off for charity
and you feel pretty good about it
whenever the economy goes down
corporations have the same opportunity
to kind of clean out part of the garage
so while the news is bad make all of
your moves
follow that when the news gets bad don't
just lay off people if you've always
handling you know got a couple projects
here I'd like to write off I had a
couple things we're not sure about clean
out the garage this is 80 economy
affecting and 20 percent People are
cleaning out the garage like right now
Yahoo is taking the opportunity if Yahoo
was still public their ticker system
would be wly what's left of Yahoo they
are just a shell of themselves private
Equity bought it to squeeze out what's
left of the advertising money that comes
out of Yahoo and they're making a buck
on that but it's a shell of itself and
they're using the opportunity to cancel
some things and do this in line with
everything else so this is eighty
percent the economy and 20 percent uh
bad decisions and you know Google's
saying oh we hired too fast so now we
have to trim it back that's what they
said last week that's a form of cleaning
out the closet and then take a look at
this remember when everybody said oh
this is just a tech thing this is just
Tech layoffs yes remember that yep the
number of companies that have made
layoff announcements is now slightly
more than 200. holy two hunt tech
companies or no no companies and that's
like more than 100 layoffs there's been
now the tech companies are leading with
200 companies that have that have laid
off more than a companies that have laid
off more than 100 people or more is 200
of them right now correct that's a real
number these are who knows but what he's
saying is companies that have laid off
more than 100 people that's the number
yeah you see and now the headlines are
coming out of eight seven thousand from
didn't see 15 000 from Google those are
big numbers I mean that's like you know
when you take 15 000 that's like laying
off a university there's universities
yeah 30 40 000 people let me ask you uh
you mentioned that Google uh Yahoo had
an opportunity to buy Google is that
what you said Yahoo had an opportunity
yeah Yahoo said now Opportunity by
everybody what year was that do you
recall I don't know for I know they had
a chance at buying uh uh a Twitter for
six billion but Google stories a
different story you can see it right in
1990 Larry Pages are given founders of
Google expect approach Yahoo to sell
Google for one million dollars
today they're worth 1.24 trillion
dollars is that a real number that's
only a trillion dollar mistake so why do
I bring this up like that's amazing it's
crazy it's crazy so like let me take you
back in time we all remember it was
around 2000 dude I remember in the late
90s literally asking my buddy who was
like a tech nerd at the time I go hey uh
Jeremy what's the difference between uh
the internet and email he's like oh you
ner dude you're talking about the late
90s midnight nobody knew like we we
think about oh the attacking social
media and big it's like you're you're
aging yourself 100 you you keep you have
to stay 39. first the donut now this I
full-on admit that I was alive in the
late 90s I was I don't know despite
contrary not a vampire we were just
selling that it was your third ninth
birthday and then you go save them yeah
thanks a lot third time but I just I I'm
using this as an example of how Yahoo
was like a leader or thought leader a
business leader at the time and now
they're sort of like a joke I mean they
lost out a trillion dollar I remember at
the time going to search information on
the internet and I went on to Yahoo dot
com this is the early 2000s and I
remember a friend of mine goes yahoo
use Google I said Google yeah yeah and
the guy goes Google and I go have fun
with your Google buddy I'm a Yahoo guy
yeah talk about getting it wrong yeah
and I remember these conversations
because right now it's like just Google
it Google it how often do we say just
Bing it just Duck Duck Go it just Yahoo
it it's not a thing it's Google just
Google it yeah use the Google machine
but just to let you know how the mighty
have fallen Yahoo was the company in the
early years it was it was all it was all
Yahoo but about how much how much
percentage of all those time do you guys
think remember we were talking about the
last podcast Amazon all these they're
all laying off how much does that have
to do with AI and now the AI is taking
some of these jobs that these people are
doing not it's not as it's not
significant right now but I mean it has
to do maybe some of it I don't know by
the way let me just give you what Kathy
would said here's what Kathy would say
she says Arc in invest CEO uh Kathy
would explain the real reason behind the
tech layoffs this is her argument
according to stock picker and Arc invest
CEO Kathy with technology companies are
cutting jobs as they harness the new AI
tools and other Technologies to increase
productivity and provide new products
and services with States
stated that these layoffs should not be
viewed as a sign of Technology sector
being in this array but instead as a
correction from over hiring during the
height of the pandemic more than 300
Technology firms including Amazon Apple
Zoom Dell and IBM have seen layoffs in
2023 nearly a hundred thousand job Cuts
since the beginning of the year the
beginning of the year was just six weeks
ago five weeks ago it's not like the
beginning of the year according to what
AI is playing a role in the layoffs
as it provides new avenues for
amplifying productivity would even
predicted that by 2030 Amazon will have
more robotic employees than humans so
Vinnie our AI expert what do you think
is causing please because you're right
so tell us what it is I right yes I mean
just just think about it because uh so
who was talking about it yesterday I
think it was on on Rogan's podcast that
the new update the part four of the chat
gbt is coming out the way that they were
talking about Lex Friedman it's scary
that in the next 10 15 years they're
literally going to take over and so it's
going to ruin uh Society because
everybody's gonna be unemployed people
are going to have the jobs and then I
don't know about that I'm just that's
what that well think about Pat I think
it has to do with other if right now you
have somebody writing a story that I
could easily just type in gbt and then
just tweak it a little bit why do we
need that human being doing it
you know what I mean so so you you're
right I think the the thing
to uh uh put there is the the reaction
so for example uh we can come up with
content here we can get chat gbt to give
us a script on what to put up there for
what do you call it
um uh you know how to respond to this if
somebody says this how do you respond to
that and how do you respond to that okay
great you can put that on there there's
no problems with that we are enamored by
human beings who independently can do
things that others cannot do we're
enamored by that Hollywood acting if you
can act a role and get me to believe in
the movie fences when you watch Denzel
you don't love me I don't love you yeah
you hey you have the others you see that
and but you've seen five other people do
that part that was done Years Ago by the
famous legendary actor who passed away
you know like what a great you see Leo
when he does the bear on top of him
before the 19 year old girl this bear
was on time that one movie what is the
movie's name the Covenant uh what is the
name of the movie with the you know
what's his name
by the way you hear Tony Robbins speak
and he's like moving an audience and
he's you know are you here
listen forgive me for you know that's a
whole different story by the way you
watch that you watch Steve Harvey tell a
story have you seen Steve Harvey tell
the story can move it I gotta tell you
Steve Harvey is maybe one of the top 10
best storytellers in the world today
when he tells a story you could find
yourself seven minutes later saying what
the hell did I do just the last seven
minutes yeah you so Chad gbt cannot do
that because you don't see the emotion
behind the machine we are not turned on
by machines have you ever physically
been turned on by a machine and say man
I'm emotionally attached to this this
doesn't mean there's an entire billion
dollar industry I was just gonna say Rob
yeah robot video Once
the fear with technology has been around
for a long time yeah and and and the one
thing with us as we age Vinnie yeah and
we start worrying about uh end of the
world and you know and you start talking
about these kids are lazy and they don't
know when you start making comments like
that that's the first sign of you
getting gold I'm getting old 100 but
here's my thing though I'm talking about
20 years from now because mind you we're
not the beginning stages if this thing
is getting smarter smarter smarter yeah
Pat the robot you know I saw in China
they have wrote they had dude I saw a
fleet of these Chinese robots and it's I
oh I went to a restaurant with Kelly a
couple weeks ago yeah I'm not joking
they had like one or two servers we
ordered the food a robot came out with
everything gave us our food gave me my
drink and I was like can I get a refill
yes the thing left brought me my I'm not
was this robot hot I'm gonna tell you
something right now what was her name
did you get her number
I don't know I don't know the name of it
but I looked
I looked at podcast career I mean they
were Advanced bro but Pat what a little
it's a little cart you know that you
know Roomba that runs around your I have
one I have one I have a relationship
with them I'm single but picture a
Roomba that kind of has a little radar
in it so it doesn't run into Furniture
it just kind of goes around with a with
a big post on it and a platter on top
and you're yeah they put your food on it
no but but Tom when it dropped off my
food it kind of looked back to me and it
went like it made like a noise that
robot was into me yeah I think I think
Pat is basically sort of winked when you
get a Diet Coke refill yeah I think Pat
is saying that certain elements of
humanity cannot be replaced so for
instance I agree you know we went to
lunch a few weeks ago to a restaurant
called Hooters yeah shout out to our
friends at Hooters hi girls I don't
think there's ever gonna come a time
that Ai and robots are gonna make it
called rooters okay like the robots
aren't taking over Hooters
you remember your Yahoo
you're gonna be an old I remember the
podcast I'm telling you right now it's
not gonna happen soon but I'm saying
it's happening because I think some of
these jobs are going do you think do you
think so okay so let's play this because
I think there's there is fetishes like I
had I had a i when you're in the Army
you learn about a lot of weird things
with people with fetishes because when
you're doing late night guard duty of
course you've done that before you're
like what are you doing bro hey man dog
it's my fetish you know can we keep this
time I get at least you know dude
anyways I'm not gonna get into specifics
yeah but the classic but but here's the
part here's the part fetish is fine but
I want I want to ask you this question
let's let's say 30 years from now okay
you're 69 years old 30 years from now
however I'll be 70. you're gonna be
seven seventy okay 30 or 30 years from
now you're gonna be 70. okay
you're at a restaurant relax 75 74. shot
like we're doing like particulars you go
to a restaurant seven years from now 30
years when you go to a restaurant okay
and at this point this restaurant is
known
for having the hottest robots in the
world okay by the way technology is so
Advanced that they are 100 scored in a
way where what men think is beautiful
they look just like that their skin
feels like regular skin they have every
feature yeah a woman has yes she comes
and serves you food okay
you flirt with her yeah I know I am I'm
old would you hook up with a robot 100
am I gonna get a virus I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna have a feature though well if
they don't like you that robot can cut
it as well if she doesn't like Bobby
John it's gonna be like oh boom one time
you're going there at that age that
thing is well no with the way technology
is going to be working when you're dead
well with the reverse aging pill I might
be but listen in 30 years can you even
imagine how hot like I'm not gonna lie
are you gonna care like are you would
you hook up with a robot I 100 pack with
some of the videos that I've seen yeah
100 Vinnie you would hook up with a
robot yes I would and I've been 30 years
from now in 30 years I'm telling you
guys your Yahoo Google you're gonna
change your tune yeah in 30 years what
these robots are listening you know
consider me old school I just kind of
like hooking up with regular human women
you're saying that you're saying that in
2020 old school like you're saying in
2023 in 2060
trust me your tune is going to change
bro that's it you're leading the low bro
the robot Brigade of uh marketing to
start banging robots I'm gonna be I'm
not saying bang robots I'm saying I'm
gonna be an old man by them but what I'm
telling you is that technology is going
to be ridiculous because they're going
to look spectacular I saw what I was
doing something on the podcast was going
to be funny I saw one of those ones that
just sits on your couch it looked
ridiculous it was it wasn't like robotic
just wait 30 years you see what's gonna
happen do I see your face earlier you're
like wait what you'll see I'll show you
one have you seen that one where half or
ahead of this thing how did we get here
we were talking about I'd love to get a
bell question he asked the question he
says how much of this is AI I said
here's what Kathy Wood said about it
then I said here's our AI expert Vinnie
and then he went talking about uh Robot
porn and then now we're here later can I
make one point about our friend where
okay bring it back to the point yeah I
think I think you know we tend to forget
we just went through a worldwide
pandemic for two years where it was like
what goes up must come down
money printing inflation Insanity
lockdown supply chain with like this was
the the global economy stopped for a
full-on year especially depending on
where you were in the world and things
are kind of restarting again and Kathy
said everyone thinks the technology
sector is in disarray but here it is
instead this is just a correction from
over hiring during the height of the
pandemic Kathy Wood I never heard her
name prior to 2000. she was one of the
darling investors of covid okay does it
I'm gonna ask you Vinnie does the name
Eric Juan ring a bell
everyone
no okay he's the CEO founder of Zoom he
went from a relatively Unknown man to
arguably the most needed famous man in
the world at one point because he's the
founder of Zoom now Zoom it's like it's
like Zoom little base time we're back in
we're back in human interaction now
right what does Lincoln say uh circulate
amongst the troops yeah so I think we're
going for this correction I'm talking
about is that we've gone from like
completely relying on technology for two
years so like all right let's just get
back to normal and essentially a lot of
these layoffs because of that Tom what
do you think about this whole
conversation about relationships with
robots I'm actually I want to ask it in
a most serious way possible you your dad
was a rocket scientist you're a guy that
went through IBM's training you're a guy
that was a professor at biolo Adjunct
professor at Pepperdine you've been all
over the place you've been in technology
you've been in it you've been studying
following this industry for a while so
you know the Good Bad and the Ugly do
you think it'll come to a point where
people will be dating robots and they're
going to be replacing relationships all
that stuff well I have two very distinct
thoughts yes the first is
um don't worry about the robots it's
just jobs are going to be different and
people are going to do different jobs
it's like when the when the saddle
Tanner a Tanner is a guy that works with
leather and when the saddle Tanner saw
the first car he's like oh man my my
saddle business is screwed if this
catches on right because he's making
saddles for horses and all that kind of
stuff and these waves go through the
economy and technology and advancement
happen the jobs are different point one
point two if you go look back at the
dawn of
the last like five technology Cycles
the internet
DVDs by the way
um you know what drove D you know what
um drove multi-prospective DVDs remember
you could watch a movie and change your
perspective on it porn
porn and CES Consumer Electronics Show
tried to keep it off to the side porn
was took full advantage of VHS they took
full advantage of DVD porn talk about
the internet and and what happened there
there's always been an element where
people use technology to fulfill vices
so that I think that's going to happen
with robots and I think it's bad for
relationships I think it's bad for the
human relationship but we've seen it
happen before with technology and Pat
think about this we're kind of joking
around I'm joking about it but you know
I'm a freaking comedian but what I'm
saying is bad thing about this it's
people like us obviously we wouldn't you
guys you know girlfriends married
whatever whatever I'm not talking about
the average guy that just watches porn
on their phone and we're not paying for
it it's the guy that you know like they
get the subscription they're watching it
they're alone trust me those guys you
give them the opportunity of a robot
that's in the house that they can hook
up with and dude what was that movie
Joaquin Phoenix uh do you guys um it was
just her her it was um Scarlett
Johansson was just a robot in his ear
and he was had a relationship bro wait
till that becomes darkest most annoying
movie annoying movie bat but look at how
it was horrible it was just the top 10
worst movies I've seen and I love
Joaquin Phoenix he's one of my favorite
thing about how cheap that movie was to
make just her voice in his head that
said walking on an office he was a they
made like Hallmark cards we should make
a a version of that yeah from like a low
budget and we should call it he him
foreign
I just I can't I'm trying to have a
relationship with my ex I don't know by
the way the more I think about it here's
here's what you're making me think about
so okay so porn was what VHS yes I'm
trying to buy the original movie covered
sealed of Rocky one and all in this one
auction and the uh Godfather but the
first one was VHS okay Denver VHS it was
VHS you know in the army barracks it's
got like a thousand porn VHS on top of
each other and said this one's the best
one this one's this so then you go DVD
then you're saving files on a computer
then it went Napster then it's phone
easy what is the the main site it's
called whatever the new porn sites are
there's a couple of big ones and then
from there you're gonna go virtual
reality what are you doing after virtual
virtual realities they're doing that so
maybe the next phase after virtual
reality is gonna be where some guy is
gonna have a robot I'm gonna take a
lunch break he goes on his lunch break
why is your truck going up and down
her it's her my V2 2200 it's a you know
2029 model I just bought for 17 grand
listen I know you've had a rough week go
on my truck just make sure you're not
too crazy guys to but look like here's
the question though God if if will the
Optics change if you know how right now
if somebody says something about this
girl he's gonna forget it but then maybe
it's okay it's a robot I don't give it
you say yeah your robot is a piece of
that's and guess what that's she's a
[__] okay are you gonna be offended by
hell probably not no pal no I don't know
man I'm concerned about this direction
we're going I did in the pan I saw a
video I saw a video where the guys and
this was I was somewhere in Asia there
were in the virtual stuff people are
sitting there watching and the the guys
humping this machine that's set up as if
I swear to God as a female but he's
seeing a really hot person I swear to
God what kind of porn do you watch I
wasn't born it was on Duck Duck Go Duck
Duck Go with bro oh yeah I'm just saying
just mark my words I'll probably be dead
by then you'll see what's gonna happen
okay watch how this technology changes
let's transition out of this story
shout out to our show shout out to Scott
Rodriguez seven months Insider he's
gonna be with us on February 23rd
looking forward to seeing all the guys
that are coming to the 500 and
subscriber on February 23rd thank you
thank you
so it'll be here at the uh yesterday I'm
at the building and I'm seeing the Cigar
Lounge being built with the public oh my
God yeah it's awesome it's awesome can't
wait for that thing to be done and uh
what we'll do with that here in Fort
Lauderdale but speaking of movies
annoying movies we're talking about this
movie I watched a movie this past week
here we go you didn't like it at all we
go I watched a movie called The Judge
the judge yeah what an annoying movie
why in the nicest possible way I mean
you're you're
I want to know why you were so adamant
that we needed to watch that movie
there's so many different elements it's
literally the exact opposite
relationship you have with your father
that was like what I was thinking the
whole time I'm like why is Pat wanting
me to watch us to watch this movie
because because you know to some it's a
father
to some it's a mother to some it's
another relationship to some it's an
uncle to some it's a grandfather but no
matter what it is
people grew up mostly most people grew
up with a complicated relationship with
somebody they love that nobody knows
about yeah it's you and them okay and
that movie to me the judge the
relationship with the father watching
that guy first of all I thought I
thought about a lot of people and I
recommend I thought about you because
you kind of remind me of the actor on
how he plays that's kind of like
you know how you are and to see that
setting how they're avoiding each other
and it's like hey hey and you and then
at one point when you actually want to
tell your dad what you want to tell them
and then he tells you what he tells you
that's so painful that you want to kill
the guy when he says those comments and
then the the siblings are just trying to
bring everybody together and unify but
it's a it's a real movie it it depicts
so many different things that people are
actually going through I thought the
judge was an incredible and then the end
how the judge ends up being judged and
such a and he uses that opportunity to
say I remember I was going fishing
together when we were a kid yeah yeah I
remember and you're like wow yeah and
then how he dies and just great I don't
want to give away the engine but the the
I mean the relationship with with the
father and the son is very emblematic to
what I was dealing with my dad my dad
wasn't a judge and I wasn't an attorney
but that just that that love hate
respect all I want to do is earn your
respect I love you but I hate you and
like there's so many emotions to me the
like the the the the thing that I
remember the most is when he you know
he's like I I didn't do you want me to
defend you in in sports yeah like he was
a judge who basically was
um uh allegedly murdered somebody in a
car yeah ran someone over and then he
became uh on trial even though he's a
judge whole complicated story he goes do
you want me to defend you because Robert
Downey Jr was the I think Tommy some big
some other state yeah big city he had to
go back to some small town Podunk town
in in Indianapolis or in Indiana and
um you know he dropped like a little
one-page contract he wrote yes because
he couldn't say it to him yeah exactly
checked yes but at the end he goes you
know I you know when you ask me who the
best attorney ever was and I told you
someone else he goes I just want to let
you know that it'd be you wow wow and
that's all the son wanted to hear she's
like I'm proud of you that's right he's
like I went to this school I went to
Northwestern and I did all this and you
didn't even say great job nothing like
all I want to do is seek your validation
I became an attorney you're a judge all
that he goes yeah and then he died right
there on the boat oh my god with him and
he just said how much did you cry be
honest I didn't cry like you were almost
freaking emotional right now
I think you're absolutely right I think
it's whether whether it's you and maybe
your mom or maybe me and my dad me and
my dad whatever relationship you have
there's someone yeah you're like why
don't you just get come on and to see it
come full circle and then and then on
the I don't want to give it away but
when well I guess I'm giving away it's
an old movie guys I'm on the boat yeah
and he doesn't even try to like no he
doesn't do nothing he just because he
was in jail and he's like I know because
I think he was like in the leave of
absence good behavior yeah and he didn't
even try to save his life he's like I
want him to die here outside on the boat
yeah not back inside unjust yeah so
powerful and when yeah cancer in the in
the bathtub oh my God and the daughters
can I come in no don't come it's just I
mind you it's a tear Jerk It's a tear
jerker and when you're like somebody
like me because comedians you know we're
really messed up people because we have
all the problems that's what's the funny
thing about us when a serious moment
happens like that and I feel myself like
I'm about to cry I automatically have to
go to Comedy and my mind I was like oh
[__] like in that moment I'd be like I
didn't do it because they have a shitty
relationship I'm like because now you're
gonna bring that body back to Shore and
be like listen I know we hate each other
but this was not me but thank you for
being a vulnerable for a second because
you know the whole time I'm thinking why
is Pat recommending this movie has got a
great relationship with your father like
you're the type of you have the type of
relationship with your father any son
and father would want genuinely but
maybe like you said maybe it's not your
father maybe it's your mother maybe it's
a sibling maybe it's everyone has those
complicated relationships I want to hear
is the person you love say hey great job
yeah something simple and the fact that
your father can't even say that your son
can't say their mother say that hey I'm
proud of you yep that's all some people
want to hear some of it so great great
recommendation right first of all I mean
if you have never seen the movie The
Judge go watch the judge yeah it's on
who it's on the Hulu I think yeah go and
watch it and see what I got it on
YouTube phenomenal phenomenal movie well
yeah thank you you did your homework man
that's good stuff
we need more movies about the human
condition that takes relationships
together whether they're documentaries
or things like this these are these
movies we need because I I I'm long-term
I worry about you know media and just
the the numbing of everyone on CGI and
Ant-Man wasp 3 and things it's it's like
I want my kids to have opportunities to
see movies like this about The Human
Condition because then we can talk about
being a person you know you don't talk
about being Ant-Man at the end of it
yeah and that's what made um The Last
Avengers so powerful when Robert Downey
Jr dies right remember how powerful that
was oh my God how different it was it
was no longer an Avengers movie it was a
man at the end of his life who had
achieved his quest and movies about The
Human Condition like this we need uh and
by the way you know maybe it's also
because I'm a big fan of Robert Downey
Jr with his fall and his rise and you
know somebody said the other day here's
Robert Downey Jr is a perfect example of
somebody who went from being a boyfriend
equality to a husband quality you know
how he changed himself the way he did
it's a phenomenal story of what he's
done to himself anyways if you haven't
seen it go watch it somebody just
commented right now eight month member
Michael uh Peterson he said grew up
without a father it was impactful to see
how tough love works phenomenal movie
Carlos thank you for the Super Chat and
I think Michael also said something else
somebody said Adamo Daniel good uh Godoy
who's been a member now for eight months
uh he said Adam makes me nuts but glad
he's not gone yet
thank you glad he's not gone thank you
Anna you're starting to grow on people
man people are starting to like you
right now
give it time next story next door Andrew
Cuomo Andrew Cuomo blasts Biden over
migrant crisis Andrew chromoblast Biden
after migrant crisis
and Andrew's going to be missing for a
minute he had lunch one time with
kellyanne Conway everybody talked about
it and now he is back Andrew Cuomo
former New York Governor criticized
president by the open board and policy
calling it a mistake and unprepared in
the latest episode of his podcast matter
of fact Cuomo stated
uh it was a mistake for President Biden
to open the Border without having a plan
to handle the tremendous flow of people
Cuomo also accused the Biden
administration of not understanding the
consequences of enacting their promises
and said the southern states were right
that opening the Border created a
tremendous hardship for them to handle
they were right that the federal
government was not prepared Cuomo also
spoke on the uncontrolled flow of
migrants
and its impact saying the border is not
just the Gateway for people but for
drugs this is on top of a homeless
problem that has already strained
resources and urban areas my one
question if it's not for when we talked
about this especially when Roland was
here too if it's not for the votes and
we're not talking about these people I'm
talking about their kids kids down the
line they're all going to vote Democrat
because I'm I'm pretty sure they're
going to be the ones that say listen we
had the Border open remember to vote for
us if it's not that what is it because
don't try to tell me that this
Administration cares about minorities or
they they do not care what is their
actual motive if it isn't that patent if
it's not the votes because it's not oh
we love immigration it's the Statue of
Liberty is a symbol and we or oh no no
it's not that what is it what it would
if you had to guess not it not being the
votes what else if you were a Democrat
what would you what would be your
defense what's first of all it's Optics
if you remember do you remember the AOC
picture at the border yeah can you go to
the picture of AOC emotional
yeah you know and what it looked like
and she's at the border yeah and that
was too trash Trump of course okay has
she been back there and taken similar
pictures under these guys of course
she's not okay so this is called
politics this is the dirty side of
politics some are better than others
she's one of the best she's probably in
the top 10 best you know gamification
dirty politics manipulation she's won
the best she wouldn't have 30 million
followers on Twitter if she was a lover
or hater she plays she's like Patrick
Beverly she's like Ron artez she's like
these players that would know how to
throw the elbow and piss you off Chris
Paul how annoying of a point guard he is
to get the foul and flop and all that
stuff that's the Optics okay you either
can do it or you cannot do it she's one
of them okay now
on the other side with long-term voting
first of all if you ocl if you leave the
Border open
who are they coming to see anyways
they're coming to see who the the who
the the people that are cross on the
border who are they coming to see other
family members okay so you're winning
whose votes their kids and their kids
you're winning people's votes who are
already living here's families coming
today very true so that is a vote that
you want okay so then the people that
are coming in who are you winning future
voters is what you're saying okay great
but it's such a major issue that if you
don't go and talk about it the media is
not talking about it the left doesn't
have to talk about it mainstream media
doesn't have to talk about it however
the problem today is the following the
problem they're going to face today is
the left itself is done with Kamala end
with Biden did you see the story about
what Hillary Clinton said about Kamala
Harris two days ago just read that story
or no what she said have you seen this
where it's circulating ever so Hillary
Clinton is on this tour going all these
places in India India's her new Haiti by
the way just so you guys know oh [__]
really the next Target for her is Haiti
she got money from lady the next Target
for her is India if she targeted Haiti
remember how much money they got from
Haiti and the money never ended up going
to the actual people well now she
started getting India next she's been in
India this past week going around oh my
God here's what's going on climate
change is really hurting you it's
getting hotter stuff all these strange
comments she's making but this is what
happened this week about her comments
regarding Kamala Harris top Democrats
are questioning vice president Kamala
Harris's leadership abilities and former
Secretary State Hillary Clinton even
reportedly
Hazard doubts members of Congress
Democratic strategists and other major
party figures all said she Harris had
not made herself into a formidable
leader uh Monday article from New York
Times by the way so this is not New York
Post okay this is times times in an
article said member of Commerce
Democratic strategist and other major
party figures like all said Harris had
not made herself into formidable leader
the piece said two Democrats recalled
Clinton privately dismissing Harris
chances of clearing a presidential
primary field because she lacked the
necessary political instincts two
Democrats recalled private conversations
in which former Secretary of Hillary
Clinton's the upstate Hillary Clinton
lamented that Mrs Harris
could not win because she did not have
the political instincts to clear a
primary field a spokesperson for Clinton
pointed to their strong bond although
the times didn't quote him issuing his
specific denial of Clinton's reported
private thought so there you have it so
this kind of going on so the Border
thing that you're talking about if it
keeps getting worse and worse and it is
it looks like it is 8 000 people a day
no problem then eventually if people
don't want Kamala and Biden to run again
the first thing they're going to do is
they're going to talk about but look at
the border crisis do you understand what
I'm saying so it's it media has a uh uh
Ace in there
Ace in a whole sleeve to say pinch the
bear yeah don't pinch it yeah they
haven't they have an ace in their shorts
to use that in case something happens to
say bingo go after we need to get
somebody else running go ahead I think
you're absolutely right there's things
that are behind the scenes here the
first is
Cuomo has been given the green light
remember who's the Border girl or vice
president
yeah yeah she hasn't been there yet
right I will eventually get there
um the um
so number one he has a green light to do
it number two he is looking for a
Centrist position for his own person you
know Cuomo's not done he doesn't want to
go to Palm Springs and retire you know
Cuomo wants to be relevant and he's he's
got to re-emerge and reinvent himself so
he's coming out with this very moderate
measured position for himself he's been
given the green light to actually say
something like this by the machine and
last week ABC news is saying things like
you know we just ran a poll here at ABC
News
um actually one of them four I think
they're worse off since the start of the
Biden Administration I fell off my chair
when I saw that so there's more things
like that that are going on Hillary's
going out saying these things they're
all trying to do one thing and one thing
only I see the phrase clear a primary
field now they're not trying to clear it
they're trying to build it and they're
trying to build it without the current
president in 24. WoW speaking of Cuomo
are you
um predicting that Cuomo's gonna kind of
give a run in 2024. I I don't think so
but do you think he wants to sit on the
sideline and smeared with doing half as
much as Bill Clinton ever did and yet he
has to sit on the sidelines as the as
the you know hashtag metoo Governor that
got blown out they didn't want that he's
not going to sit there he's got too much
pride and too much
and he's coming out here yeah with a
very balance this is a very balanced
honest story but I guess my question is
the southern states were right ladies
other than his own legacy which is
clearly tarnished at this point yeah
what do you think his motivation is what
is what does political instincts leading
him towards I think the machine is back
there putting these out but what is
Cuomo's he's asking you what's Andrew's
motive I think it's Andrew here's a way
to take a couple steps back here's
something here's something to come out
there and be you know man that people a
couple steps back what does he want to
accomplish what though I
the guy doesn't want to retire and the
guy's got aspirations aspirations this
is purely speculation does he want to be
a pundit does he want to be involved in
the DNC is he running for something now
clearly he's not running for governor of
New York again well he loves being in
front of the camera if you offered him
an opportunity to kind of make a
comeback on MSNBC and be in front of the
camera he'd take it if you offered him
an opportunity to it and then and then
have a platform and the political stage
with the DNC I think he'd take it he
wants to be a deal maker he wants to be
a king maker he wants to be who he was
as the governor of New York and he
doesn't want to go quietly into
retirement who do you think has more
political legs or uh you know a brighter
future ma uh Andrew Cuomo the former
Governor or Chris Cuomo the former CNN
pundit or Chris Cuomo became a media guy
pure media guy yeah Andrew I think still
has legs what do you think Pat I know
you were big fans of them during the
pandemic
listen for me obviously you know what
what the whole cover-up brother all that
stuff that you know Chris got criticism
for which it's his brother what do you
think he's going to do he's gonna sit
there and when he's praying at night and
he's talking to his dad you know and his
obviously his dad's no longer here but
when he's talking to his dad praying
whatever you're doing and saying hey
what should I do that you back up your
brother what do you think Mario his
father told Chris and Andrew when they
were small saying hey you guys better
back each other up 100 till the day I
die you better back each other so I
don't see Mario as a lightweight father
I see him as a strong wasn't he a
two-term governor or something like that
he was supposed to be a president and he
chose not to run last minute and some
people said it was a big mistake because
if he would have ran he would have been
a president he still didn't want to make
the decision to run this is not look
just look at the way he looks
he's a tough he's a boss yeah he's the
kind of a dad that would raise some
tough guys yeah so to me
I don't know I think Andrew uh is
sitting around saying you know the Cuomo
people remember today is not Mario Cuomo
the Cuomo people know today no today the
only people that know Mario Cuomo
they're probably 50 plus okay 60 plus
and they're gonna go away yeah and
they're in New York right the Cuomo
people know today is the two brothers
those two guys to be honest with you
here's what I would do if I was those
two guys this is what I would do
I would sign them in a heartbeat I would
sign them in a heartbeat right now if
they did a show together two brothers
and I'd give them a nice amount per year
and could do show the two brothers you
got so much history of what to talk
about with you know and you there'd be
plenty of guests that would be willing
to come on your show and I think people
on the right will be willing to come on
your show yeah you don't need CNN to
these guys they think like that's the
place to be CNN MSNBC CBS ABC [__]
those guys on you guys if you go do
something like that go take the podcast
route do a show together and leave a
different kind of a legacy of hey here's
where I screwed up here's what I did
with this but let me tell you guys the
experience we got here's what our father
raised they can talk how their father
raised them they can talk Brothers they
can talk family nucleus they can talk
Italian stories they can talk food they
can talk who's better with the mom who's
a bigger mama's boy they can talk so
many different things they're the kind
of guys that you know I have friends in
my life that I fully disagree with
politically but my gosh I enjoy having
dinner with them right those will be
these guys I think they're very
marketable uh I don't know these guys
I've never the only thing I think one
time we had a communication trying to
get Chris here and he asked for a big
numbers to be I'm like dude we're not
doing that we just want you to be on the
podcast or not anyways that was a
different experience that we had
together but I am a very uh big fan of
them on the way they are with their
families okay again someone's going to
come back and say you don't know what
they are let me take their backgrounds
tied to the Mob all this stuff stop if
you walk on water fine all I'm saying to
you is they're very marketable these are
two marketable guys that can do
something with their legacy and
if I was a son of a Cuomo and Mario is
my dad okay and I'm talking uh having a
conversation in my head with my dad my
dad I'm gonna be like hey man there's no
way in the world you gave us this last
name we're gonna let our last name end
the way it is ending right now and the
same people that we brought all these
eyeballs for Andrew Cuomo did all this
stuff for New York Chris Cuomo did all
this stuff for CNN all of those eyeballs
you about now they want to crucify you
and hurt your last name oh hell to the
no so but that's me yeah I don't know
how they're gonna handle it but I think
that'd be a great thing not to cut you
off Adam I just just really fast I think
that something like that where people
that were on like CNN and they're just
all the left going on a network or going
like on a podcast that you don't have to
read a script you know I mean you don't
have to be a political activist just we
want to talk to you I want to know who
you guys are you guys remembered in the
pandemic uh I think Chris did a joke
about his brother having a big nose I
mean it was during where you know people
were dying in like uh old person homes
but he he was like Hey with your brother
people think of a big Q-tip making fun
of his nose that Dynamic that brother
Dynamic would be something great to see
not on a CNN it's it's it's it's it's
it's for TV now by the way you know
Christmas podcast is not doing that good
right now you know because you know you
it there's okay so the world of TV
here's a question here's a question to
ask okay so guys that play traditional
basketball who they play fundamental
basketball okay and they go play street
ball and give me the top Place rocker
park or they go play in Venice Beach and
you're playing with some tough tough
guys right fundamental basketball is one
thing playing with tough men who are
gonna elbow you hurt you talk [__] to
you if you're playing for a Christian
basketball league and then you go there
it's a major shocker when you do that
right okay fighting in a organized ring
boxing with gloves versus go to Thailand
or go to certain places where they're
doing
five thousand dollar bets it's a very
different climate Okay doing TV on CNN
Fox your team has got 40 employees whose
job is to make you look good okay the
teleprompter the script the writer the
stories the person telling you you're
reminding about this remember November
28 when he said this he said this 19
years ago and you seem so smart because
someone's no one's feeding us [__] right
now the only thing we hear is our own
voice this is hard oh yeah so to go from
there to doing this super hard by the
way it's also hard for people to go from
podcasts to do what Chris and them do
you know why because we're long-winded
um mm-hmm I don't know if you understand
what I'm saying of course you're going
to keep it lighting time like when I'm a
damn bongino it's like hey so so Pat hey
so Patrick we got 30 seconds left okay
a different format big time so so for us
to make that transition there is not
easy for them to make the transition
here it's not easy we don't like
mainstream because that's not how life
is life to me is an explanation of what
you're going through it may take 18
minutes I don't give a [__] about
commercial Cuts we got to cut to
commercials here's Pfizer take some more
such and such all right and if your
thing lasts more than four hours with
Cialis call a doctor we're back here so
let me tell you what Kamala Harrison
said it's a freaking so for us what do
you think Tom what do you think about
this Rob how do you think so so this is
the part where Chris going from
mainstream to podcasts very few people
know like Russell Brand is a great
podcaster but he tried to go have his
own TV show it flopped yeah it's it's
not it's not uh
even movies he had a shot with movies
too it was like wow he came in and came
out he did have a major hit though
switch on inside of you inside of you
what
you're so brand yeah Forgetting Sarah
Marshall I I know what I'm saying is he
had like little guest star rules but
what are you trying to do what are you
talking about the song was a hit
but then he tried to be like in the
movie Arthur and I mean get into the
Greek his career shirt oh my God he's so
freaking Speaking of Chris Cuomo I just
went and because I knew you were gonna
go talk because he does have a podcast
that launched almost a year ago I think
in uh April of 2022 so it's been nine
months look at the guests that Chris
Cuomo can get he doesn't get a ton of
views a couple of his yeah only two
videos of over a hundred thousand views
two yeah he doesn't but here's the guess
that Chris Cuomo has had on his podcast
talk about a-listers Bill Maher Whoopi
Goldberg our good friend Neil deGrasse
Tyson Stephen A Smith Sean Penn Alec
Baldwin anybody he'll get it Tyler Perry
Joe manchin Andrew Yang Paul manafort
our old friend over there your friend
Noam Chomsky Bob Costas I mean Dr Phil
Tulsi gabbard dude gets but no eyeball
but no eyeballs because he's not on CNN
he's like in the basement so Chris if
you're watching valuetainment uh would
like to have a conversation yeah cool
I'll call almost bring your brother why
not listen obviously this is not a pitch
they're gonna they gotta go to the
people that they're comfortable with
because that's where they got to go but
all I'm saying is if I was somebody
that was in a safe space for them that
they would want to go create content
with I would in a heartbeat pitch a show
between the two of them together I put
the show between two of them together
and throw a middle host you know
somebody like in a you know that's and
then they can do whatever they want to
do people come up current events
politics business stories family
everything yeah all right anyways
hopefully we got them a job but let's
continue here let's continue here let's
continue let's talk about uh this guy
named uh uh uh Donald Trump let's talk
about a story with this guy okay every
time we tell stories with him some
people are happy some people are upset
but let's do it anyway so
the idea is to try to be Fearless so
here we go all right so
so let's go through this that's not Ron
is it ex-president Donald Trump post a
photo of Florida Governor DeSantis
allegedly drinking and partying with
high school girls okay
so here's a picture if you want to put
it up uh former president Donald Trump
posted a photo on the truth social which
was allegedly showing Florida Governor
Ron de Santa's drinking and partying
with high school girls more than 20
years ago in the photo a young man
appearing to be DeSantis as seen sitting
on the couch with three high school
girls alongside with photo president
Trump wrote that's not Ron is it he
would never do such a thing Trump also
reposted a message made by another truth
social user who indicated that the
message read Ron DeSantis was having a
drink party with his students when he
finished high school teacher having
drinks with underage girls and cuddling
with them certainly looks pretty gross
and uh how do you pronounce that word
[Music]
okay you know Trump didn't reporter was
uh taken by when the sentence was
teaching history and government at
Darlington school in Rome Georgia during
2001 2002 School according to the New
York Times Two former students both
women remembered him attending the last
two parties where alcohol was served
they said that the parties took place
after graduation and that they were not
bothered by his presence at the time
although they question it now one of the
former students was quoted saying it was
his first job out of Yale he was cute he
didn't really think too much about it
okay so there's two things here one the
picture two Trump posting the picture
Okay
um
I'll open it up Tom if you want to go
first tell me about the picture what do
you think about the picture and two what
do you think about Trump actually
posting a picture uh I I don't know what
to think about the picture if it's if
it's really DeSantis you know a teacher
going to a party and there's alcohol and
they're underage that's that's certainly
not good judgment but that's also when
when was this and the other thing is I
don't think Trump's got the moral
authority to talk about this particular
topic really if you're going to come out
and and go after somebody you you know
you got to have you got to have the
moral authority to do it and I just I I
think there's so many other things that
are going on that basically this is mud
Boogeyman you know politics here I think
Trump should stay on the message saying
hey this is what I built I gave him the
opportunity to be Governor this is this
is what happened instead he runs a
picture like this and the backlash on
this was pretty severe you know there's
a lot of people that are on the right
that were like dude you're not this
doesn't help us this doesn't help us in
24 and I don't think this is a good
angle so I'm uh not good judgment for
DeSantis way back in the day if it
happened as it's being shown I mean if
this is the if we're seeing pure truth
out of this and I just it disappoints me
I think we need to elevate this and we
need to talk about all the things that
are that are important and it just seems
like a cheap distribution but here's my
question did you do you expect anything
less from Trump the santis is is the
enemy because he he's going to go
against them this is just showing you
bro that Lover's doing this mind you who
got this picture that's that's
opposition research on your opponent hey
those girls you know notice how at the
end the girls are like uh well you know
it didn't really bother me but dude all
it's gonna have to take is Trump to
bring one of these girls out to one of
these debates about put her in the crowd
and be like yeah now she's actually
changed her mind and she was like it was
this right Packers I mean he's notorious
for doing that yeah but that mind you I
mean to me that doesn't even look like
him I don't know if it is him but for
him to say something like uh grooming
the high school girl something like that
it's like bro how old was he 26 I think
24 23 no well in this photo no he was
funny if I'm just doing basically by the
way you and Ron DeSantis are literally
the same age I think you're a month
apart yep okay so he's 44. uh
I think it's I want to say September if
he does get elected he'll be what the
second youngest president ever yeah this
is what this would be
you know 18 months from now so he's 44
he'll be 45 46. I think JFK was the
youngest ever elected at 43. so if I'm
just doing basic math here Ron was 22
years old here partying with 19 year
olds yeah 18 year olds this is par for
the course in college what are we
talking about here yeah this isn't a big
deal talk about the knock on Trump is
you know Miss Universe he goes into a
lot of the pageants these girls grabbing
him by the you know so like this is
Trump
this is what he does if you don't think
that Trump is sitting back and thinking
is this round and sanctimonious yeah I
built this man yeah you don't think he's
probably about to get Petty and jealous
how the hell is he beating him in the
polls right now of course by the way I
don't think a year ago we're having less
than a year ago nine months ago we had
Christina Pusha here we had other people
Weighing on whether we thought Ron
DeSantis would be running for president
yeah I think at this point when you're
leading the poll you have to you're
running yeah about his moment and the
fact that he's the now favorite just
picture this a year from now we're going
to have Republican primaries it's going
to be Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis on
stage that's about to get very
ugly and I think this is my opinion I
think Ron is going to sort of take the
high road he's not going to play in the
mud with Trump and Trump is just going
to look Petty and just kind of come out
of him with little things like this and
I don't think it's going to be a good
look for Trump but what point but at
what point do the gloves have to come
off for him because bro there's only so
much that well mind you this guy's Navy
you know I mean how long is it going to
take for a Navy SEAL dude who's been
through this [__] to just be like you
know what dude I'm done do you think
he's not gonna give in at all that's not
easy bro I just I think he does not
benefit from from going in the mud with
Trump you know what do they say that
Never Wrestle with the pig because uh
you both end up in the mud and the pit
act the pig actually likes it yeah he's
gonna he's gonna he has a year and a
half to take the high road take the high
road take the and it's just gonna
highlight how Petty will be what do you
got this Pat you're smiling for
something nice and there's already four
now sununu says that this 90 certain
that his exploratory committee has found
the necessary funds
going so I have Nikki Haley we have
sununu it's sununu's doing what are you
saying the governor of uh New Hampshire
is running he's gonna run these are
notes these people have no shots these
are just for their resume I ran for
president what were you giggling about
because I wanna so here's here's the
thing yeah do you remember
have you taken jiu jitsu martial art
have you taken anything have you ever
taken anything what'd you take you took
what I did when I was a kid I was big in
Taekwondo you took Taekwondo what did
you take Tom I I did not
[Laughter]
here's why I'm asking this question
here's what I'm asking so my son goes to
jiu jitsu yeah okay and I go and watch
him
both of them he took me out on your boat
you know that right did he really did
you didn't have to cook honestly did you
feel it I swear to God look at these two
Rascals Tico got me in the headlock and
guess who comes Dylan grabs his wrist
and pushes more and I'm seeing Stars I
go this is a team Penny on a serious
note I sworn our friendship he got me he
locked it in I've told him don't do that
to me they think it doesn't hurt no no I
told him don't do
anyways anyway go ahead so one day 20
years from now they're going to watch us
and laughing so funny bro so they're
doing Jiu Jitsu right and I watch them
I'm like okay hey you go on top all
right hey so you're going so you do this
so you do the aren't they doing it
they're fighting they're doing all that
stuff okay great so imagine if you're
the best jujitsu guy yeah within that
environment okay okay which there's
guidelines there's roles you can't do
this you can't do that say you do this
for 10 years okay you're a black belt
you're double black belt I don't know
your black belt with seven red stripes
we can tell you what take whatever you
are okay jiu jitsu
and then you go fight with this other
guy
who has never done Jiu Jitsu but he is
accustomed to fighting with knives
the people he's fight with they have
they shank they they have uh they hit
you
yeah they have beer bottles it's a
street fight it's a brawl the scientist
has fought in confined environments
mm-hmm he's about to fight a street
brawler you have to understand it's a
lot easier for the street brawler to
beat a confined person than for a
confined person to be the street brawler
by the way I may be wrong somebody may
say well no you've never fought someone
I'm just telling you this Trump has
fought people in New York that they were
political people and he was able to get
the permits and this and that and all
this other stuff but he's also one in
business and he's also going to become a
president so Iran has to understand you
are about to face the dirtiest you know
smack talking he's gonna do everything
and anything to beat you are you okay
with that yeah if you are guess what get
in the ring yeah and and Pat he's bitter
he's bitter too I I think you make up a
great point I agree and I'm going to
give you a little bit of push I'm being
a lack what is an analogous is what I'm
now like yeah I think you are right the
one knock that I will say on Ron is he's
already being sort of crowned the next
president United States before he's
really been on the national stage he's
obviously done well in Florida run real
one reelection he's crushed it killed it
he was supposed to win by you know four
points he won by 24 points whatever it
was and he's sort of being coronated
before he's actually earned it president
was
um and I think that's for a multitude of
reasons
um where I or I will say that your
analogous might be off is that it's
still going to be confined because where
they are going to debate is going to be
on the RNC State that's not going to be
in a primary that's not going to matter
what do you mean I'm saying that that's
we've already seen yeah what Trump did
to Little Marco Rubio it's a low energy
jet like he has a blueprint of what dude
to expect are you are you telling me
this okay did you see what he did to let
me go through the list of names of what
he did day one
um
day one Jeb Bush starts with 140 million
dollars he's at the debate okay day one
and he's doing the debate while he's
going through the debate let me see if
there's music in this if there's music
in this I can't play it because it's
going to be a uh what do you call it
restricted but if there's no music in it
I'll play it for you to see what he does
day one okay when he came to debate Jeb
Bush Jeb Bush has 140 million dollars
he's starting off with Trump has nothing
it's his own money
in date is there music hang on day one
he destroys Jeb then he destroys Marco
then he destroys uh uh uh what do you
call it uh Ben Carson sweetest man then
he destroys Ted Cruz then he destroys
one by one by one by one by one by one
by one literally destroyed then all of
this is being built out to face the
dirtiest politician in the history
I'm with her
okay I want you to watch this play this
real quick we can play this because
there's no music Rob I want to send it
to Rob yeah I'm going to text it to her
I just want you to watch it and see how
eloquently he destroyed Jeb Bush okay
you guys are thinking like this is gonna
be a fun match here listen the the
training you get like for example you
know street fighting shooting guns the
other day you and I won a shotguns you
said something very interesting where
you said it doesn't matter if you shoot
every single day when the first time you
pull and you hear that the first one you
feel right okay and you saw it was me
you and Sam by the way just so everybody
knows just everybody knows
I've been shooting for a long time
but I don't shoot pistols I like
shooting rifle M16 rifle that's my
that's what I like
uh Adam
this guy we shoot the body I'm in the
Square when I'm shooting okay so 99 of
my shots are in my body On Target
Vinnie's not on target
no no I'm not I'm this is like zero
jokes here
a hundred percent of any shots was in
this circle did you hear what I just
said Tom two hours later 100 of his
shots are only in the same Circle so
then I'm like Vinnie what the hell are
you doing guess what he says dude I was
an MP in the Air Force for seven years I
was on a shooting team it was insane how
amazing this guy was but some things you
do in your life
you may be good at it and then you go
with another person's like dude I'm like
dude I thought I'm going to be good I
looked at Vinnie I'm like dude Vinnie's
here I'm like down here in this game
he's about to go with somebody that's
been doing a freaking 60. just watch
what he does his first debate Jeb Bush
140 million dollars he's supposed to be
the next president let me give you Jeb
Bush's resume his oldest brother is the
president his father's a president his
grandfather was Senator Prescott this
guy is supposed to be the next president
and he was a two-term governor of the
great state of Florida and then look
what Trump does to him watch this
let me talk quiet
foreign
what he says is there's all of the
donors is when we talk to the RNC the
RNC said we can't bring anybody here
says I don't have any guests here these
are all RNC chose the guests and the
donors to be here and all the people
that are in Durham are Jeb Bush's people
and it says you think I'm lying to you
here's what they did I couldn't bring
anybody so whatever you're hearing so
immediately the viewer went to all these
people that are booing Trump were paid
and were paid to be there boom that you
can't there is not a manual for you to
read to know how to handle those types
of situations yeah I agree you and I can
sit with the top 50 greatest Debaters of
all time and I can invest a year into
you and say every day for eight hours
these guys gonna teach you we're going
to spend 10 million dollars to make you
Bulletproof on how to debate right a
year from now I'll get good 60 years
60 years good luck if I train how long
do I need to train
I want to tell you this right now how
long do I need to train jiu jitsu and
UFC unboxing how many of the greatest
instructors in the world can train me I
put a 50 million dollar budget for me to
train for one year straight how many
hours and dollars do I need to do to
train to be Jon Jones
the answer is what say it again never
say to my face you'll never beat Jon
Jones in a fight no matter how much
money in one year you're 100 right yeah
this is the part that people are like
underestimating by the way I'm not
sitting and telling you who's a better
candidate for America I'm not sitting
here talking to you about politics I'm
not talking to you about any of that
stuff you're fighting Jon Jones
this is not a regular guy Yep this is a
Jon Jones Street brawler you best bring
it because he's gonna get you dirty and
he's very comfortable with that you know
guys come after us and they call us out
and so let me tell you Patrick because
this this recently what happened this
last weekend and they did another live a
couple days ago yeah do you have any
clue what I've been doing last 23 years
do you have any clue like what kind of
dirt other people at the games Dominic
like do you know even the life so when
somebody said what are you doing you're
making yourself look like a clown when
you do some of this stuff right but more
power to you keep doing what you're
doing
this guy is a street brawler and you're
about to go against a guy like this so
whatever they're showing this is really
what it's going to come down to
the only thing it's going to come down
to is to follow
Democrats let's talk Democrat strategy
if I'm in the Democrat strategy
strategic side here's what I'm doing you
ready if I represent behind closed doors
I'm a strategist I'm the guy they bring
in but no one knows who I am okay this
is a killer no one knows who I am and I
ask I will only help you guys if you not
once mentioned my name and I want to
sign contract if you do I can sue you
for a billion dollars you can't ever
mention my name yes perfect
here's what I'm doing game number one
create a civil war
do whatever you can to show any kind of
polls any kind of quotes to piss off
Trump
put up as many polls of people saying
the sentences ahead
the more good quotes you put about about
the santis being ahead of Trump trump
doesn't know how to handle that because
he's a psycho competitor he's going to
go for the sentences throat
when he does the scientists can only
take so much eventually after thousands
of text messages of did you hear what
Trump just said about you
you're going to be sick of touching the
phone or you're going to be sick of
people saying did you hear what Trump
said about you and he's going to say I
don't give a [__] then eventually in a
press conference someone's going to ask
something he's going to say something
back and they're going to poke him boom
Trump's going to use that as ammunition
to come after him and he's going to keep
hitting that over and over and over and
over and over again then
the left wins because once they find out
who their ideal candidate is going to be
whether it's going to be news from
whether it's going to be Biden whether
it's going to be Hillary whether it's
going to be Michelle all of that content
that they're going to get for one year
is going to be used against the front
runner on the Republican side yeah
that's the strategy of the left and I
feel if they have the right people
they're helping them out that's exactly
what they're going to do to these two
guys it's called divide and conquer
they're going to play it over and over
and over and over again and the way you
do it the content has to piss off who
first
Trump everything has to be about pissing
off Trump not the scientists yeah you
don't need to piss off the scientists
yeah because the census is going to be
like yeah whatever you need to piss off
Trump and Trump is going to go after
disinter so again by the way I'm not a
political strategist this is not my
world I'm more of business strategist
I've played a complete difference behind
closed doors games that I've you know
doing things that I've been a part of
but Watch What Happens here the next 12
to 18 months I agree with that and
because I think the left has to have
something to go against it because
whoever does come out from that side is
going to be the favorite unless the left
has something up their sleeves like that
like the whole Russian collusion
[__] that they tried they have to
have something what is it going to be
you know what I mean there's only one
thing there's only one name what
Michelle Obama I mean that's yeah I
don't think that's the thing well you
know here's like everything you're
saying is accurate everything you're
saying is right
in 2016. because you know how they say
what a difference a year makes this is
eight years later Pat eight years later
I think at the time there was such a
yearning for something different whether
you like Trump love Trump hate Trump
despise Trump what he did in 2016 was
absolute an anomaly we've never seen
anything like that in American history
this guy comes on stage shushing people
making fun of people bringing like
Clinton uh assailants on stage like this
is reality TV's finest my only question
is this is the schtick getting old is
the [__] getting old as an example we're
talking about movies when Jurassic Park
came out or The Avengers came out or
rocky oh my God if you've seen this
dinosaurs when Jurassic Park 7 came out
it's like all right we get it the
[__] dinosaurs eating people
and that's essentially what I'm saying
here in 2016 Trump was Jurassic Park
holy [__] I've never seen it it's like
now he comes out again he does his thing
it's like we've seen the movie Donald we
get it and that's the only reason Joe
Biden won the election in 2020 is
because people were done with the movie
we've seen it Trump you're doing the
same thing over again sleepy Joe
you know who's you know it's not a trump
thing it's not it's not a DeSantis thing
it's not a buying thing we're gonna find
out what the population thinks what
American thinks and we're about to find
out yeah I think there's a yearning in
this country for we're done with the old
men we're done with Biden we're done
with Trump we're looking for something
okay you think the world is based off
your yearning you think you think that
America you think the world and
competition where there's any kind of
competition is based on the yearning
really do you think that's what it is
let me ask you another question here how
old is Dana White right now is Dana
White getting old is UFC getting old is
Conor McGregor talking [__] getting old
is
fighting getting old it's people who
talk [__] getting gold is Jake Paul
getting gold is Logan Paul getting gold
is Andrew Tate getting gold what if you
were to say what type of personalities
or creating a ton of momentum the last
five years what type of person is it
more desensitive steps or personalities
more Newsome type of personalities more
what kind of personalities
trolls that are growing the last five
ten years because social media favors
trolls and eyeballs and attention well
no doubt but but here here's the other
part here's the other part that you're
not even considering but by the way who
do you think I want to be president
between the two
who do you think I want to be proud I
want you to actually think about the
answer there who do you think I want to
be president when I think about Trump or
descendants here's all I want you to
think about before you say Trump why not
I wasn't gonna okay when I think about
Trump or DeSantis what is the most
important thing I as a father as a
businessman as a man care about what I
care about a role model in leadership I
would assume I want right policies I
want you to leave me alone I want you to
let me work I want you to let me build
my business I want you to don't over
regulate every freaking day you wake up
I want you to leave taxes in a
reasonable number that we're paying
taxes these last three years every year
has been the most taxes I've ever paid
in my life and every year I want to say
the last three years every year has been
the most taxes I've paid in my entire
life I don't know if that makes sense or
not the 2019 was the best most ever you
would know these numbers with mine
because you know my numbers 2019 2020
was the most ever combined then 2021
became the most combined ever since the
day I was born then 2022 was the most
combined ever since the day I was born
it's been back to back to back I don't
have a problem just show me the results
on what I'm getting I'm good with that
I'm looking for policies
but this is not about who you want who I
want this is about who's going to win
and what the strategy the sentences Camp
has to know you have to be prepared for
who you're going up against think about
what ammunition this guy has watch the
question I'm going to ask and I want to
see your answer you ready I'm gonna ask
you a question here right now and I want
you to process this
and see how quickly you come up with it
give me the biggest endorsers of Barack
Obama when he ran in 2008. Oprah Winfrey
exactly it's the first thing I was gonna
say and you said that okay how big was
Oprah Winfrey the biggest huge okay who
else endorsed Obama everybody in
Hollywood everybody in music industry
everybody in sports everybody and
everybody okay
tell me the biggest endorses of Donald
Trump
from Scott Baio by the way look how
you're joking yeah I'm not joking but
but literally thinking but think about
how quiet you got nobody doesn't need it
what's the point he doesn't need
anything this is not a guy that some
people are away he's gonna need this
endorsement because that's not going to
work you don't understand this is a guy
that doesn't give a [__] if Elon Musk
wants to endure some or not he doesn't
care if the you know biggest guys want
to endorse him he's not that guy so
here's what he should probably care I
agree if I'm sitting down interview him
I'm gonna say why would you call Elon
Musk what are you doing Elon on your
side but that's that's the right
question to ask but in I'm telling you
how I see him I may be wrong but the way
I see him is he doesn't give a [__] if
you endorse someone I think it's the
challenge he gets in his own way but go
ahead he does but he's proven like
there's a part of him that he's shown
and said hey you want to be on my side
great you don't want to be on my side
get him out of here get somebody else to
replace them whether that's right or
wrong it's not what your what the way
you would do it it's work for him no
doubt it in 2016 is very explicit what
does he have today that he didn't have
in 2020 when he lost you ready what he
has said he that he did him in 2021 Ruth
social no who gives a [__] about truth
social I don't care about truth so
neither do you know what he has that he
didn't have in 2020. people can't be
this naive bro what he's got a chip no
forget about the Chip he's had a chip
since before he was born when his
parents conceived them there was a chip
already in the shoulder this guy's born
with a chip okay is it all the stuff pad
that's been exposed with all the Twitter
files the New York posts
everything that he said that he said now
he has proof yes Russia was fake fake
Twitter files New York Post Hunter Biden
I should have been president they were
wrong this and and you can't say
anything to that gain a function there's
nothing you can say to that he's gonna
say look what did you see what fauci
said this week with CDC and vaccines no
did you guys see the article without you
this week well we should be very careful
with the MRNA because some of the things
will have to be just this is just a
couple days ago by the way I don't know
if you guys before before you shift
gears can uh because you're gonna go to
show I'm not trying to shifting all I'm
saying to you is just think how a great
Storyteller and a marketer and how great
troller he is he has more content today
where he can give a five hour speech on
this and he'll keep going and going and
going and going and going now Twitter's
got him back Facebook's got him back
Instagram's got him back Google's about
to give him back he's got truth social
he's got all this other stuff and you
give him all this content I mean this is
like yeah by the way fantastic Point
fully agree and then here's my advice if
he makes it which I assume he will if he
uses the word I versus we I told you
this I was right I called it if it's if
it's that people are over that he's
going too but yeah that's my point for
sure but if he says we need to
understand the American people we all
under like yeah he definitely if he
makes it about him and by the way you
know what else is gonna you know why
this is all playing into his hand
here's what's going to be playing into
his hand what's going to happen all year
long this line did you see what AOC did
the other day with fake Hunter Biden
laptop did you see what she said have
you seen this that's true she's like
this is half half true Hunter Biden fake
laptop that everybody on the
conservative sides want to talk about
and investigate that's a sign of
weakness 100 so the next 12 months
you're going to see fauci being
investigated you're going to gain a
functions what I'm trying to tell you is
that does not help DeSantis that helps
Trump because all of that worked against
Trump yes that didn't work against the
Santas what the Santa says going on is
the following nobody in America as a
governor handled covet scoreboard
leaders bulletin beta nobody handled it
better than him that is a salute
everyone's given him well he went from
34 000 votes to one and a half million
votes that's where he's at but there is
a
there's another dimension to this game
of politics man that there's a very
different dimension to this game of
politics
you kind of asked the question and so
you asked who do you think I want to see
yeah president yeah do you I don't have
it I don't I literally don't know I'm
curious what do you think
I don't know I I I I I who do you think
you would have vote for either one of
them who do you think
I
I think we're on the same page yeah you
know
am I rooting for DeSantis no but when I
objectively look at what I think he
would do as a president so I could do
this this and live this this and this
that's who I'd kind of like to see
um I look at taxes I look at things that
are going on in Washington right now and
I just roll my eyes and I'm like this is
incredible and I say you know I think
DeSantis would be a moderating force and
all that but I think about it the same
way you did it's you know it's it's like
who would you like to see when the Super
Bowl and who do you think is going to
win the Super bowl or who do you think
is going to walk through those playoffs
and I agree with everything you've
you've said I I think America doesn't
understand the core Trump voter and they
are about to be energized by exactly
what you said I was right yes that is
powerful I was right yep so I think I
don't know did you give an answer sure I
did I did very clearly I said would I
like to see DeSantis as president for
the moderation and everything okay
sure if he's going to manage the country
the way he managed Florida then you kind
of trust that guy and say he's going to
keep the peace and I'll be able to do my
thing
for you Pat well I'm saying I don't
think he'd probably be mad I don't think
you'd be mad if like obviously we see
with the scientists very good very
attractive candidate but going back to
the trumping I don't think he'd be mad
that Trump I don't think he'd be mad at
Trump one because at least this time
he'd get a kind of a fair shot with all
the [__] that was against him I've said
this before at least he'd be having like
no Trump no no Russia no there's no
pandemic if they don't release you know
if China doesn't have another goddamn
outbreak but I I'm not going to front if
you flip the coin I wouldn't give a [__]
which one would you pick for Pat I would
say for me I I honestly wouldn't care
I'm being badass zero I don't get I
don't give a [__] because
but here my point though during Trump
during Trump the only thing that was
hurt that was hurting everybody and
people feel like bro when people pick
one this isn't it I Trump because I want
to see him have a a fair shot without
the Russia [__] without this without
[__] fouchy without all these [__]
I'd want him to go by myself his own
question so let me so concerns concerns
of what
I worry about this is what I worry about
what is the last thing left to do to
Trump that they haven't done yet and
item
they've pretty much done everything on
Epstein Island there was a video of him
doing something there he literally kill
him that's it okay by the way we already
killed his reputation they killed his
business and killed everything about him
so that is the last thing that's left
which is a play a card that was used
against Kennedy against Reagan against
Lincoln against RFK against MLK I mean
there's a list of by the way we are not
condone no no no no
hell no all I'm saying to you is there
is different forms of assassination
character assassination is very very
very hardcore Financial assassination
it's hardcore when you don't have any
money and what like what a bunch of the
guys from New York Giuliana used to be
hero in New York now think about how's
he making money they took his license
away from him this was a guy that you
loved when 9 11 happened now you want to
trash to go because he become someone's
lawyer yeah you know you got a few other
names on that list so they're going to
do Financial character typically if you
do Financial it's done it's done when
you do Financial they can't do that to
him character assassination 99 of the
time it's done he's Teflon it doesn't
bother him there's only one thing left
so my concern is that and it may not
even be from the states and maybe
somebody else all this other stuff that
just is not happy with this guy becoming
the leader because if he becomes
president tariffs are coming back China
is going to be miserable he's going to
expose him he's going to make the
tribunal court with you know where did
covet come from gain a function you know
there's going to be so many people that
don't want him to be there trust me
Democrats are begging for DeSantis to
win to be the lead or their strategy is
to make sure Trump wins but give him so
much content that whoever they put up
against him and there's only one or two
people that can be to Trump if they go
up against him Michelle's one of them if
I'm on the left right now you have no
idea how many conversations I'm having
with Michelle Obama please please you
have no idea how many conversations I'm
having Michelle Obama they feared that
Hillary is going to get in there because
you can't prevent him who's going to
tell Hillary don't run and she listens
nobody nobody if Hillary's gonna run
she's going to run Hillary sees herself
as an equal to Trump he Hillary sees
herself as he and by the way to me she
is except she's not marketable yeah and
she's not a good speaker she's not so to
go back to it I want policies I'm
concerned about age I'm concerned about
whether you're going to last and stay
energized to fulfilled so even if he
gets elected in a year and a half two
years January 2025 is going to be
inauguration how old is Trump going to
be January 2025 probably 80 almost so
you mean to tell me you're going to go
till 84. he's a pretty healthy guy he's
golfing he's walking he's active he's a
guy he doesn't drink no drugs he doesn't
do drugs he doesn't do any of that stuff
but that's the concern the scientist is
younger all of that stuff so you know
it's it's
the policies the scientists I believe
will drive I believe Trump will also
Drive they're about to go do character
assassination on Biden I believe on uh
DeSantis I believe the next nine or 12
months and we've not yet seen how he's
going to handle that if Trump was
elected in 2025 2024 he would be 78
years old when he steps foot in the Oval
Office for the second time so 82 years
old right now Joe Biden is currently 80
years old yeah he'd be younger than Joe
Biden if he were to get a second yeah
yeah is your pick Trump my pick is
either way but I have concerns with both
of them okay I have concern I am I have
concerns that they
will because some okay so sometimes when
you have a squeaky clean resume
sometimes when you have a squeaky clean
resume what happens what's the what's
the fear of somebody that's squeaky
clean they're hiding something here
buddy but but so so everybody plays a
facade we're all playing a facade your
facade is what I'm a comedian I'm a
funny guy yeah okay all right Tom's
message from the outset for people that
don't know if you don't know Tom what do
you think Tom is
Christian man good father who knows a
lot has done a lot of business he's got
good takes that's time yeah you are
trying to change a bit of your story
where you're going from good boyfriend
fun guy to hang out with you you'd like
to be a family guy and get married and
have kids am I wrong or am I saying it
pretty correctly I'm going through a
growing up phase yes okay but you're
recreating yourself sure in this in
essence right but if somebody say we go
three months ago you know what somebody
would say about you that's a guy that's
made his money he you know he's having
his fun he's good with the ladies he's
well spoken he's a good host he's chill
that's Adam right every one of us has a
certain thing I want you to think about
the most score person in your life
you don't need to say the name you don't
need to say the name but think about
person you know think about the most
Square person in high school growing up
or in life yeah think about the score
person okay okay do you know that square
person
your mom would always say why can't you
be like we had these couple friends my
mom would say why can't you be like this
person why can't you be like that why
can't you like oh my God so freaking
annoying but this when the stuff came
out of that guy was doing drugs that guy
was doing this that guy was like oh my
God I'm like I'm so glad I wasn't so
when stuff was like well Patrick yeah
okay okay but the scientists
MO
is
squeaky clean yeah big time so the
smallest little thing about him is going
to get a bigger reaction if somebody
said right now that you know Trump has
got a girlfriend in you know South
Florida that you know such and such you
know what you would do that we may not
even cover the story it's like obviously
whether it's true whether it's not true
it doesn't matter if it's true or not
when you play this like this is why this
is why I don't like to talk about that I
go to church and I do all this I don't
like to talk about that because to me
every time people get into too much
Jesus too much Bible too much this those
people who did it too much to kind of uh
uh what do you call a like like put one
up you know right I've always been very
careful uh uh when somebody uses the
Jesus card against me I'm like yeah you
know what the people that I know that
follow God and are living the good life
they typically don't go around
doing away the way you're doing it and
using it to kind of feel like you're
more Christian than I am and you're
better than I am and I don't relate to
that and quite frankly those people walk
on water and they eventually have a very
hard fall so that's the concern both
sides is that the analogous uh metaphor
I'm trying to be analogous and fearless
of them buying at the same time Jesus
let's all hold hands here let's take a
moment no but but you understand the
point I'm trying to make exactly that's
my fear yeah one story is wrong yeah of
having a girlfriend or whatever this
story is with the drinking you're saying
that's going to carry a lot more weight
because it's so new and he is is not
used to these Trump would look at that
picture and Trump will look at that
picture and I'm like
yeah he's either going to say what yeah
I don't remember that or that's not me
yeah oh well look at them they're
actually pretty hot so what does that
say about me he's going to say something
like that hahaha you move on but
DeSantis this is going to drag one month
two months three months four months five
months with Trump it's a one day story
with the sentence it's a six-month story
yeah well so here's what I can guarantee
yeah this Trump the Santa story yeah it
ain't going away anytime soon oh no it's
gonna get hotter and hotter 18 months oh
yeah get used to it buckle up yeah Pat
what'd you mention about AOC what did
you what she was talking about the
hunter Biden laptop yeah she said she
was saying and can I say the Twitter
hearing yeah can I say one thing because
there's a lot of that going on right now
all the house Judiciary hearings about
Twitter and all that yeah I want to say
one thing why the hunter button laptop
is so important okay because what people
fail to understand it's that whole story
isn't about the crackhead painter son of
the president it's about the president
of the United States while he was in
that laptop has all these dealings with
the big guy Tom that is with China with
you Crane and with Russia that see
they're listening to us and what people
don't realize is what's going on on the
global stage right now we're we're
giving all these billions of dollars to
Ukraine to fight Russia China is flying
freaking uh spy balloons over and we
don't do nothing to them you understand
what I'm saying Tom like he is so
compromised and that's why that's why
and I hate because I have liberal
friends have to keep going here you go
again the hunter byline so I go I don't
give a [__] about Hunter his father is
all all in there and they're doing
everything they can to stop it I just
hope those investigations that you're
talking about come out because like you
said with Trump saying he's right Pat
that idiot left these laptops and that
Delaware spot yeah everything is on
there pointing at his father and him and
he was The Bag Man and nobody gives it
by the way it's the year of
Investigation well let's see hopefully
it it ramps up I'm telling you I said
this January 1st this is the year of
Investigations it's going to be a very
shitty year in that in that regard but
but I'm gonna tell you two things and
then we go after some we go into some
serious topics like Super Bowl
predictions beautiful
um here's here's what I'll say to you
if you're in the camp
in the camp everybody has
skeletons in the closet
so what the camp doesn't do is
investigate each other
okay let me let me kind of unpack this
yeah when you're in the camp whether
you're a McConnell or your Schumer
whether you're Pelosi or your McCarthy
whether you're whoever if you're in the
camp
you don't investigate each other's
to put him in jail and to do all that
stuff it's like a code got you you don't
think Mafia stuff it's omertas exactly
you'll do well let's play we got to
raise money so then there are certain
people who don't want to be in the camp
okay
when somebody outside of the camp comes
in and doesn't want to play the rules of
the camp they will go after you and take
you to court
Trump's not in the camp okay the
scientists they would much rather prefer
dealing with DeSantis Yale who's gone to
Yale Bush Kerry so Yale you got Congress
you got Navy SEAL military in the
military you have to learn chain of
command I mean there is that there is no
chain of Commandments yeah so it's not
I'm not just saying that but it's going
to be a lot easier dealing with a
DeSantis
Scent of a Woman it's going to be a lot
easier dealing with the scientists then
it's going to be to deal with Trump
exactly so 100 they would much rather
prefer the sentence as a president than
Trump because
you understand the code yeah okay
there's you know you know how kind of
like Roland Martin was here the other
day says when's the last time you saw
cops you know whistleblowing on each
other okay guess what
maybe there's some truth behind that
yeah of course okay sure there's also
some truth behind politicians kind of
doing that to each other so I don't know
you know obviously listen this is why we
run businesses we do podcasts we have
opinions this is not CNN this is not Fox
we're just talking yeah regular people
like everybody else and we're sharing
our thoughts and opinions with you and
seems to me when I see the viewers it
keeps climbing and more of you guys want
to hear conversations like this because
some of you guys may sit there and say
your OG soy boy Community some of you
may say I relate to Doc which we can't
wait for his show to be released here
soon that's going to be sick on Mondays
we'll release it we'll tell the details
here soon it's coming very very soon you
know some are coming here because they
want to see what you know our sniper
Vinnie has to say yeah you know and and
but or some come here for Malik for rap
you know who knows I mean especially
after last week but regardless let's
let's finish it up here with some Super
Bowl predictions let's finish it up here
with some can we put pole Rob put a poll
who's going to win the Super Bowl Eagles
or the Chiefs and so with that being
said Adam since you brought this up this
was your suggestion because our audience
loves sports tell us yeah my idea to
cover the Super Bowl yeah that's not a
big deal it's just the Super Bowl
um we're talking about the best team in
the AFC the Kansas City Chiefs and the
best team in the NFC
Philadelphia Eagles going to head to
head I think Philadelphia is favored by
one and a half points Philly the Eagles
one and a half two points I'm gonna
check right now and uh I don't know I I
I'm gonna lean on Philly I think my
home's a little hurt he just won MVP I
don't think there's a good case for when
you win MVP then you win the Super Bowl
with super MVP so I think that that
Philly is gonna eke it out by a couple
points Pat let me explain something to
you I don't know if you guys saw the
last game with KFC Kentucky Fried
Chicken
um guess what the script has already
been written Patrick Mahomes who's his
biggest who's he sponsored who's the
sponsor Patrick Mahomes who's his
biggest uh Allstate oh State Farm State
Farm guess where the game Guess What
stadium they're playing in
State Farm
Chiefs win by a touchdown 100 that's
right it's already written homie Insider
information Patrick it's been written
you saw the horrible calls in the last
game yeah it's come on who's winning it
who's winning good time 31-27 Philly and
Mahomes just coming back making it close
if there's another three minutes in the
game he wins it
so here's here's what I think so I think
Billy's going to get out in front and I
think you're gonna so we got two
Phillies we got one KFC pbd I'm gonna do
what the better did yesterday I'm gonna
go with the Bengals I think
no I think listen I like the love the
feistiness of Mahomes okay obviously I
was cheering for Joe burrow to beat him
because I'm a burro guy I love bro I
think Boro is a chip on the shoulder
away from whooping on everybody for a
decade if he can get that chip on the
shoulder but the way Mahomes plays
Mahomes gives me the vibe of Kobe MJ the
attitude the energy he's got that Brady
angry wants to beat you like his eyes
are like this middle of the game they're
down a touchdown he's not afraid he's
staying solid like it's a very very
unique characteristic that he has Eagles
have an incredible defense uh I love the
fact how poised their quarterback is
but I have a feeling mom's gonna win a
second Super Bowl because Mahomes got
one target I think he's going after
Brady uh you know the other day when
Brady announced his retirement Mahomes
posted on the bottom in the comments
section the goat which was great to see
Mahomes give him a shout out of the
golden but you're seeing the other day
when LeBron passed Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
in points and Shaq was asking uh Lebron
the question so say so tell me a young
brother yeah you know so what do you
think is going to be the good he says
man I see myself as the greatest player
of all time I see like LeBron said this
all right LeBron sees himself as the
greatest player of all time I think he's
the second greatest player of all time
but LeBron sees himself as the greatest
player of all time I think Mahomes wants
to prove a point and what better year
for Mahomes to win it than the year
Brady retired wow you got to win the
championship
I don't know it's a great show two and
two so we have to have our friend Malik
hey Malik rob you gotta break this time
so there's a Super Bowl this weekend
so we'll see what happens anyways gank
uh uh you know sometimes I sit here and
I wish we could do this five days a week
where we just my schedule does not
permit for us to do this five days a
week hopefully one day we'll be able to
do this more often because we're having
a lot of fun doing this uh I know you
got some stuff that's going on I know
you're working on some special skits
with Dylan that's gonna be on class
yesterday Jennifer's asking me hey Pat
Uh babe uh Vinnie's got the skit he's
doing that you came up with yeah he says
that and she said he's asking for Dylan
are you okay with Dylan being in a video
I said baby I know it's get it it's
going to be fine I can't wait to see it
myself so it's gonna be fun to yourself
because you guys look like I love it I'm
gonna dye my hair today so I don't judge
anyways guys have a great weekend enjoy
the Super Bowl be safe and we'll do this
again next week take care bye bye-bye